hello and welcome to this intelligence
squared event
i'm delighted to have with me today
michael pollan
he is an award-winning author activist
and journalist who has won a claim for
blending meticulous reporting with
anthropology philosophy culture health
and natural history
in 2010 time magazine named him one of
the hundred most influential people in
the world
his international best-selling books
include the omnivore's dilemma in
defense of food and cooked a natural
history of transformation and most
recently a pair of books about the
effects of drugs on the human brain
how to change your mind and now his
latest this is your mind on plants
for those who are not familiar let me
just explain the format tonight's event
is going to run for one hour for the
first 30 minutes i have the pleasure of
being in conversation with michael
myself and in the second half we're
going to be taking your questions but
you can start asking them now by
clicking on the ask question button
under the video screen and typing your
questions in the box below
if you want your name to be mentioned
type it into the box and i'll give you a
shout out
then simply press send
in addition we're also on social media
and we would love for you to tweet about
this conversation and share it with
others so please use our twitter handles
and use the hashtag iq2
so let's begin michael pollan welcome to
intelligence squared it's such a treat
to be able to speak to you
thank you goody wonderful to be here
look can i say just before we get
started that you have such a way with
book titles and i'm thinking
and i'm thinking in particular about the
omnivore's dilemma and my personal
favorite the botany of desire which is
just so good
um and those books that i've just
mentioned michael exemplify what i think
you're perhaps best known for which is
your exploration of the sociocultural
impact of food
and so it may seem that your recent
foray into the world of psychedelic
medicines and plants is a bit of a
sidestep but there's a clear progression
isn't there to your choice of book
subjects
how have you come to write about topics
as varied as cooking on the one hand and
getting high on the other
well it's all stuff we ingest right that
um
that changes us in some ways i mean my
uber subject as a writer has been the
human engagement with other species
specifically plants and i've been
fascinated
by that since the time i was a child
and um and if you're interested in our
symbiotic relationship with plants
you're going to end up looking at food
that's our most powerful
engagement with the natural world we
change the world more through our eating
than anything else we do
but there are these other desires that
plants have evolved to gratify
and that includes changing human
consciousness and that's a very curious
desire because it doesn't seem on its
face that it would be beneficial
but of course
if it weren't
the drug takers would have been edited
out by natural selection by now and
interestingly enough they have they very
much have not
um so i was very always curious to learn
what good is changing consciousness and
um
so this has been an interest going back
to botany and desire and thanks for your
comment on book titles that is my
favorite um book titles are very
difficult it took me a month of doing
nothing else to come up with that title
believe it or not it's totally worth it
i love it i think it's the best book
title ever
the previous book had a pretty lousy
title and didn't do very well and my
editor said don't put pen to paper or
finger to keyboard until you have a
great title
and so i was forbidden from writing
until i came up with a good title so it
was a very valuable exercise this title
may be a little obscure though to people
in uh in the uk
um this is your mind on plants it's a
play on a famous uh anti-drug commercial
on television which is this is your main
this is your brain on drugs which showed
a man cracking an egg into a hot frying
pan and sizzling it and then holding it
up and that's your brain on plans and
this was such a ridiculous commercial
that you know kids
getting high would just wait for it to
come on tv just so they could laugh
um
so it was one of the absurdities of the
drug war
possibly backfiring there a little bit
there i think so
so let's turn to the book itself then
this is your mind on plants now what i
think you do really well in this book is
that you intertwine uh reportage citizen
science and historical scholarship it's
what is honestly very delightful very
informative read
but
what's what's interesting to me is that
you've chosen three particular plans to
focus on
and you mentioned just now about the
universal human desire to change or
expand consciousness which is what these
three plants are all about what i want
to ask you is
why did you choose these three plants
and why now
well
these three plants represent three big
categories of psychoactive substances
there's an upper uh or stimulant
caffeine there's a downer or sedative
um opium and there's a psychedelic or
what i think of as an outer uh and
that's mescaline so these are the three
big categories of of psychoactive drugs
they're also ones that i was frankly
just curious about um caffeine
is a psychoactive drug that 90
of humanity has a daily engagement with
most of us not even thinking of it as a
drug so if you're going to examine what
is a drug which is a very hard question
to answer
let's look at something we all have a
relationship to
uh the universal drug of the west and
actually the rest of the world too so um
so caffeine had to be there opium was
there because it's really the oldest
psychoactive in the pharmacopoeia for
most of history as you know medicine was
involved with just relieving pain
and uh and opium and various opiate
derivatives were the the preferred way
to do it uh it's it really gets at the
ambiguous nature of uh of drugs that
they can be both a blessing and a curse
depending on how they're used
and then second and then mescaline i was
very interested in because
uh
i'm
curious about the indigenous use of
psychedelics um how do other cultures
use them in a way that's safe and
constructive
the image of psychedelics in in the in
the west is that they're very disruptive
and they lead to all sorts of social
problems and that's debatable but that's
the general view and
but what about a culture like native
americans who've used a psychedelic in a
productive way for a very long time
what can we learn from them
did we lose goody i am back i'm so sorry
i don't know what happened can you hear
me i can hear you but i can't see you oh
um
[Music]
i can see you
let me click there you are you're back
okay i'm so sorry about that
well you're having some weather there
right
some crazy weather here please carry on
with where did you get up to
well i was just explaining the choice of
the three the three substances they were
also ones i have a relationship to um
you know in the case of
opium i had um
had a kind of misadventure growing opium
poppies and i have some behind me right
here um opium poppy heads
um
in the in the late 90s i grew some and
and ran into this um government effort
to suppress the growing of opium poppies
even though it's perfectly legal
but they can be turned into a narcotic
and and as soon as you slit one of those
heads with a razor blade
uh you've violated the control
substances act and and could have a you
know eligible for a sentence of five to
20 years it's a kind of
enormous absurdity of the drug war so
i'm really interested in opm in
particular i guess as my from my
background as being a doctor and so i
wonder if i could just dig a little bit
deeper here with this because i was
really interested to read about
the relationship between the opiate
crisis in the us at the moment and
regulation so we know that there's been
this history of the war on drugs as
you've mentioned earlier
and i wanted you to just tell the
audience a little bit more about
what the war on drugs was really about
because my sense is that drug regulation
as it was used during that that period
was not really for public health so much
as maybe control of certain populations
yes so the drug war is presented to us
as uh a public health initiative right
and protect people against the harms of
drugs which are real
uh however we know now that when the
drug war was launched by president nixon
exactly 50 years ago
he had another idea in mind he had a
political idea in mind um his domestic
policy advisor a man named john
ehrlichman gave an interview in the 90s
to a journalist named dan baum who was
writing a book on the drug war
and ehrlichman said
it was never about the drugs
what it was about is our two biggest
enemies
nixon's two biggest enemies were
african-americans
and hippies
uh and we knew that if we made drugs
illegal and depicted them as evil
uh cannabis in the case of of african
americans and uh and hippies and
psychedelics in the case of hippies we
could harass their populations we could
demonize their ideas uh and essentially
control
them uh it's a it was an astonishing
revelation
and it really peeled back the curtain on
what had been presented as this public
health initiative but the opioid crisis
which begins in the late 90s with the
introduction of oxycontin by a company
called purdue pharma controlled by the
sackler family
turns out to have been the biggest
public health crisis of this whole
period and it began with legal opiates
not illegal ones so while the government
in the 90s at the height of the drug war
was going after gardeners like me who
were growing opium poppies in their
garden and perhaps making a mild
narcotic tea from it uh or loudnum where
you just soak those heads in
vodka
um they were looking in the wrong
direction for a serious problem uh at
the same time the fda food and drug
administration had approved this drug
which had been sold as safer than
traditional opiates uh and less
addictive none of which was true in fact
the the company well knew
that it wasn't true uh and this led to a
situation where by now 800 000 americans
have died uh since since the late 90s
due to
opioid abuse and and uh overdoses by and
large now many of the people who started
on legal opiates then moved to illegal
opiates with all the risks that come
from street drugs
of contamination of not knowing what
you're getting and how strong it was
but a very high percentage of them began
with
opiates prescribed by doctors purdue
pharma had also persuaded people in your
profession that we were under medicating
pain
and that it wasn't just something to
give the cancer patients but people with
workplace injuries should get it people
with back trouble should get it and they
kind of uh expanded the universe of
people eligible for opiates and it was
true we were under treating pain and the
fact is most people can use opiates
without getting into trouble um but as
you know as a doctor it's it's an
ever-present risk for certain people
totally and what's shocking to me is
that you know you have that quote from
erlichmann about
admitting that it's not about public
health and you know that it's really
about regulation of these populations
but also i mean i feel this complicity
of the medical profession right in terms
of
falling in line with what the
pharmaceutical industry was saying here
and it brings me on to my next question
which is
related to regulation which is when is a
plant a plant and when is it a drug and
why does it even matter
well that's a very good question um
you know yes not only did doctors fall
in line by the way many of them were
essentially bribed to prescribe opiates
in great numbers there were all sorts of
incentive programs
and the government well knew that there
were doctors prescribing more opiates
than there were people to take them in
certain regions um so there was a
looking the other way
um
you know trying to make a definition of
what is a drug and what is not a drug is
difficult um is a placebo a drug
is chicken soup a drug you know when
people give it to you and you feel
better with your cold i mean there are
many substances in food that change our
minds food is sugar is psychoactive
right if you have children you know very
well that that is
that is the eight-year-old's drug of
choice and
so i i don't think it's an easy
distinction to make um
i think that
what's really striking is that so many
plants have evolved
the the particular neurochemistry
um
to to change what goes on in our mind
and find the exact key to unlock
neurotransmitters in your brain i just
find that in
astonishing um and why are they doing it
well they start off doing it as a
defense chemical most of these alkaloids
are defense chemicals and at high doses
are lethal or poisonous to uh to insects
and other uh you know
pests their pests their enemies i mean
the thing about plants is they can't run
away right they can't move so they have
to use chemistry to draw animals to them
to do work for them like the honeybee
and then they have to use chemistry to
repel
so this push-pull they're really good at
and they have they're the masters of
neurochemistry as you know a great many
drugs uh even even modern drugs like
taxol you know important in the
treatment of cancer were invented not by
you know people in lab coats but by you
know
trees in the forest
yeah i just find that just so exciting
totally and you're right and we still
are very dependent on being able to
discover new medications by what's
available out there in the in the
natural world
and there's so much more out there than
we have yet surveyed i mean there are
hundreds of psychoactives in the amazon
for example and we have just begun to
scratch the surface of what what's out
there
totally and actually that brings me on
to um an area that i'm very interested
in which is you know
we have this knowledge about what some
plants can do because of ancient
practices in indigenous populations
um
but we also have this other problem at
the moment which is something called
climate change and
the amazon rainforest for instance is
rapidly depleting yes as a scientist who
obviously wants to be able to find
medicinal products that can be of
benefit to humanity you know my concern
is that we're going to have destroyed
the very habitats that could yield those
cures in the future but more than that
we also have a different problem which
is that
the very indigenous populations that
have this wisdom and knowledge
themselves are endangered
and
i wanted to ask you about that
relationship between
who owns this knowledge and who gets to
benefit
and how can we use these plants and
these medicines without harming the very
people who actually hold that knowledge
in the first place
yeah i mean it's important to realize
especially in the case of psychedelics
which are now being uh research is
suggesting have powerful therapeutic
effects and can treat uh various forms
of mental illness uh i think we're not
that far away from the approval of
psilocybin
which is comes from magic mushrooms
and mdma to treat trauma
but psychedelic medicine is based on a
foundation of indigenous knowledge as
you suggest so i think there are
obligations on the part of the
pharmaceutical companies on the part of
the researchers to recognize uh that
origin uh when it's relevant i mean it
isn't relevant in the case of mdma for
example which is a laboratory chemical
uh discovered in the 1920s i believe but
certainly in the case of psilocybin in
the case of mescaline where research
will be underway soon and that there has
to be some reciprocity and there have to
be efforts to support the communities
who develop this knowledge and
compensate them for it uh and this is a
struggle that i know there's several
companies grappling with right now i'm
involved with a new
center at the berkeley campus for the
study of of psychedelics and and what
they have to teach us about the brain
and we are going through this process uh
dealing with consultants and members of
indigenous communities to see how can we
take some of the money we're raising and
use it to help those communities
endure
but you're right we need to protect
these habitats also
you know where ayahuasca grows you know
um if if we're going to and some of
these things only grow in a very narrow
peyote which is a cactus that produces
mescaline and is used by the native
american church grows in a very narrow
band along the rio grande
and there it is in very short supply and
that's why i ultimately decided not to
experiment with it um that to respect
this practice which has
been so valuable to the native american
community and healing
their traumas uh trauma's inflicted on
them by white people
that um
the the way to show that respect is to
leave peyote alone if you're non-native
and
there are other ways to get mescaline if
you must have it and uh so i think we
need to be very attentive to this and
that part of psychedelic research and
and and
the development of these substances as
medicines has to pay respect to their
origins
yeah there's um there's something very
poignant in your description of um how
native americans use peyote ceremonies
to heal the wounds of genocide
colonialism and alcoholism
um but i think that mescaline is a very
interesting jumping-off point for
thinking about some of these bigger
issues i've actually got here um
doors to perception which is
aldous huxley's book which i think must
be in western literature at least the
first report on the nature of trips and
altered consciousness
um but the use of mescaline as you say
is much more ancient than that
from your own experience of it what is
it for and who actually uses it
so yeah aldous huxley's book dorsal
perception i recommend to anybody it's
really an essay it's not that long
and it it really launches the
psychedelic uh movement in the west uh
it's the first account of a
first literary account of a trip and
it's beautifully written um and it
points to what's unique about mescaline
and it's very different than other
psychedelics um
and i i had occasion to use synthetic
mescaline and basically the same thing
and same dose that aldous huxley had and
it was a fascinating experience
it's milder than other psychedelics it
doesn't take you to alpha centauri or
you know to some new dimension what it
does is immerse you more deeply in the
here and now than you have ever been
immersed you
the sensory information that you
you you just had no idea how how much
color was out there or how interesting
the grain of a piece of wood is or
um
the the ripples in a body of water and
you could study them for hours and uh
it's as if as huxley says your senses
were open wider than they ever have
before and you get in touch with the
fact
that normally we are receiving only a
trickle of the information that's out
there
which of course is how evolution
designed us right take in what you need
to survive and do things um
we need to do get get stuff done but
there's a whole lot more out there and
to have access to that was very powerful
it's um
it's different from other psychedelics
too in that it doesn't take you so far
out there that you can talk and be and
engage with other people
and that gave me insight into the native
american use of it um which is always in
a group setting
um they take peyote they pass around a
basket of peyote buttons they're all
sitting around a fire and everybody
stares at the fire the whole time
and it gets everybody on the same
wavelength
and i think that this is very powerful
when you have 40 people's attention
trained on one thing
let's say a patient or an addict dealing
with alcoholism or someone dealing with
sexual abuse or trauma of some some
other kind
and you and everyone has been called
together for the purpose of healing that
person it's very powerful it's a little
bit like an aaa meeting where you have
uh one person telling their story and
it's usually a story of hitting bottom
and reinvention
but the attention of everybody and the
support of everybody allows that new
narrative
of which is a rebirth narrative usually
to to really get cemented
um so i think something like that is
going on in the native american church
and it i spoke to many native americans
and they were very
protective of it and many would not tell
me about what goes on in the tp where
these ceremonies take place
but i was able to piece together enough
a sense of what happens there without
going myself
to to see that this was a very important
tool of healing and mescaline has been
in use in um in
what you know mexico texas which were
one country at one point for as much as
6 000 years
so we have a lot to learn from
traditional populations about how to use
these substances in a safe and
productive way
and what we see
is that they're never used or seldom
used alone
it's usually in a group setting there's
always an elder involved someone
presiding someone creating a container
for the experience
they're always used for a reason they're
never used casually or for fun
or for thrills
there's an intention about it and
there's always a ritual container
and when drugs are used in a ritual way
that there's something very protective
in that i mean think about people who
even people who use alcohol in a ritual
way observing our social rules you know
you don't drink during the day you you
drink with food you drink with other
people you don't drink and drive
people who use drugs in a ritual way are
not the people who get into trouble with
them by and large
this is fascinating michael and i'm just
going to take a quick break to remind
the audience that you can be asking
michael your own questions right now
all you have to do is click on the ask
question button under your video screen
and please type your question in and
click send and don't forget to tweet
what we're talking about here use our
twitter handles and our hashtag
iqs2 i want to go back to what you've
just said there michael about
the nature of using these plants as
medicine
and in these ritualistic settings you
know i am a western doctor i am a
scientist i have been schooled in hard
facts and the preeminence of evidence
but when i read your books i have to say
i am secretly or not so secretly excited
about the ways in which plants challenge
the medical establishment
to actually straddle two worlds that we
normally consider to be irreconcilable
so the scientific world on the one hand
but also the world of spirituality on
the other
and i want to know from you and from
what you've seen what relevance do
plants and the medicine you've seen
have for a doctor like me working in the
west and in the nhs
well you're right i mean what i find
also fascinating about psychedelic
research and science right now is it is
straddling these worlds of western
science and spirituality and it's so odd
to i remember the first paper i read out
of the johns hopkins group which had to
do with you know the title was something
like psilocybin this is published in a
peer-reviewed journal psilocybin can
occasion mystical type experiences in
healthy normal people or something like
that i was like wow
you know a scientific article on
mystical experience
but of course science studies
humans and what they do and what happens
to them and mystical experience is a
phenomenon in human brains um
so
it's totally susceptible to science now
hard science there's a kind of science
that only you know studies what can be
measured in a very empirical way and if
you're going to study mystical
experience or spiritual experience
you're going to have to rely on people's
reports of what happens phenomenology as
it's called it becomes a very important
part of this science but there's no
reason we can't do it and and the
scientists have scales of mystical
experience you know i took a scale i
took a questionnaire to see if i had had
a mystical experience and they can tell
me with some certainty that i have
um but i i think that we have to
understand that science is a very
powerful lens for understanding
humans and the natural world but it's
not the only lens and it benefits by uh
using other lenses as well or
recognizing their value there is
something called indigenous science um
it is empirical it's based on trial and
error uh it's not based on the
double-blind trial uh the controlled
double-blind trial but we should realize
that's a fairly recent artifact that
doesn't really happen until the early
60s
and
one of the things you alluded to this in
the introduction that i'm interested in
as a writer
is multiplying perspectives
that i am like everyone in the west
enchanted by the scientific perspective
and the scientific method and i think
it's very powerful and we have given it
enormous authority in our culture and
with good reason
but there are other perspectives and
that history has things to teach us and
that sometimes the poets get there
before the before the scientists and
that aldous huxley was turned on to
mescaline by a scientist who
wanted a literary account of what
happened and this was very useful to his
scientific research so i think that the
humanities and the science
sciences need to talk to one another i
think it's a very productive dialogue
and in all my books i've worked very
hard to to not privilege one lens over
another but multiply them and i think
that's how you get the fullest picture
of any phenomenon
totally and you know one of the reasons
i like reading your books michael is
exactly that because you look at you
know whatever your central subject is
and you look at them through all these
multiple perspectives but what i really
like about what you do is that you know
previously you've done it with food now
you're doing it with plants but you're
using it as a way to really look under
the hood of the way that our world
system works
in relation to what you have experienced
with opium and your experimentation with
growing it yourself and then also with
caffeine which we know has um the reason
that we use it of course is so that we
can all be productive what do plants
actually tell us about the world system
and about capitalism
well by the way i'm you know it's
morning here in california so i just you
know i'm drinking coffee i'm in a
different headspace you know this is
still the coffee hour
um they teach us everything about it i
mean you know
caffeine is a great example coffee and
tea which is such powerful parts of our
lives
are built on the backs of a very brutal
system of exploitations particularly the
farmers and the
tea pickers and
you know the slave trade had a lot to do
with coffee and
and sugar and of course
tea and sugar as you know in england go
together and always have and that tea is
essentially a medium for the consumption
of sugar in many places
and it was it was you know
tea from the east
sweetened with sugar from the west from
the indies uh and produced by slaves
that really drove the industrial
revolution
um and that it was people actually wrote
about this in england in the in the
1700s that how odd it is that our
everyday life now depends on
these people
being exploited in these far-flung parts
of the world and you know india was not
a tea producing place
until the english decided they needed a
tea producing country they could control
because they were spending so much uh
silver
buying tea from from china and the
balance of payments the chinese wanted
nothing from england and england wanted
tea from china so they decided well
let's do it in india and they and they
basically created this tea industry in
india and an opium industry by the way
um so these different plants that are
are tightly interlinked
they started growing opium in india not
to import to england because they
understood the risks of it but to export
force on the chinese against their will
and that's what supported tea in in
england um this this very um brutal
system of exploitation and destruction
to chinese culture by forcing so much
opium uh into a country that really
didn't want it
gosh um yeah what again what's so
amazing to me is you know i love food
and um
food i think
really helps to tell the story of
humanity you know in terms of empire in
terms of colonialism in terms of
capitalism now um
and plants are i mean food is plants
right a lot of our food is plants so
yeah these things are tightly liquid we
eat animals that eat plants
but it all i mean we all depend on this
primary productivity uh without plants
we don't exist
now i could probably ask you questions
all night michael but this is probably a
good time for us to look at what the
audience is wanting to ask you so i'm
going to try and feel some some
questions from them and just again a
quick reminder to anyone who's watching
if you want to ask michael a question
click on the ask question button that's
below your video screen type in your
question add your name if you would like
it and then i will be able to ask him on
your behalf and again
if you're tweeting please use our
hashtag um iq2
now
there's a lot of interest obviously in
your book um
and people are finding
the the issue around native americans
really really interesting here um
in particular this idea of peyote being
used to help heal the wounds of
colonialism so
one question that we have here from
stella is to what extent do you see this
healing being situated in a particular
cultural context so the the the healing
that peyote and mescaline can give like
what where
how much of that has to do with the
context as opposed to the drug itself
yeah i think it's hard to separate those
two things
but peyote-ism if we can call that you
know the term for the use of peyote in
this healing context
it begins in the native american
community in the 1880s which was a
moment of maximum crisis
native american culture was on the verge
of destruction and that was the
exact
set of objectives of the us government
we were
forcibly removing children from indian
communities
cutting their hair in the case of boys
sending them to boarding school
you know we're just learning about in
canada they're finding mass graves in
these boarding schools the goal of doing
this was and this was
articulated by the headmaster of one of
these schools to kill the indian and
save the man
so
and and indian religious practices were
actually illegal many of them in the u.s
until the 1970s okay we wanted to
destroy this culture
indians responded with this new ritual
around peyote
it was quiet they pretended it kind of
had a christian ambiance um you know
there'd be a bible around it really had
nothing to do with christianity but they
knew that they would escape notice if
they appear to be having this uh
christian ceremony
um and in that tp they were able to
sustain their culture and preserve their
culture and it was vitally important in
getting through that period of of
maximum
genocide and dispossession because this
is when indians are being also forced
onto reservations people who were
itinerant you know who moved with the
bison and the seasons and were not
agriculturalists were forced
onto land and really shitty land in in
oklahoma
and this helped save them and it has
since spread and they're 250 000 members
of the native american church
so would this work in another context no
i don't think you can borrow a set of
rituals a cultural container you know
whole hog from one culture and transform
it to another but i think there are
principles that we can borrow and that's
you know those were the ones i was
talking about earlier about the group
use of a chemical
about having an elder involved about
rituals but we need to find our own
rituals and that's this very interesting
process that's going on as psychedelics
become an accepted medicine when they
are it's not going to be a drug that you
can get a prescription for you know
you're not going to go to your your
local pharmacist and get psilocybin
it's it's going to be administered by
somebody a facilitator or therapist who
prepares you very carefully for what's
going to happen who sits with you during
the trip and then helps you make sense
of what happened afterwards so it's
going to be a new model and it will be
our container it'll be you know
medicalized um
but we have to find the container that's
appropriate to our culture and i think
that's going to be very interesting work
that needs to be done over the next few
years because
we're we haven't yet optimized that
container we don't exactly know
you know should it be done in a group
should it be done individually should it
be um do you need a trained therapist or
can just somebody you know with fewer
skills do it successfully all that is
being researched right now
yes and it is like a very um
kind of flourishing uh
boundary in research at the moment in
terms of
the session setting of how we use these
these these drugs um
i i want to ask this question about um
the
evolutionary biology of our systems of
the human
uh body and its relationship to to
plants and drugs and you know you
mentioned yourself
there's this amazing kind of
synchronicity between the fact that
these molecules
fit perfectly to receptors that we have
within our own body
um which speaks to a kind of
symbiosis between the plants and
ourselves and this kind of joint
evolution
of different species
one of the
our audience daniel wants to ask the
question of
why some plants are more successful from
an evolutionary biology perspective than
others so
opium and caffeine have been incredibly
successful and they have so widely used
across the planet as you said 90 of us
and on the in the i think this fact is
astounding 90 of us use caffeine every
single day
but things like mescaline are not used
quite so wide you know in such a wide
way and i guess his question is what's
the difference and what is it that leads
one plant to being widely used and
another knot
well you have a plant that's used rarely
in a ceremonial context so
and opium
i'm sorry and peyote is a very slow
growing plant
so it's not something it takes 15 years
to get from seed to
usable
cactus it's like a little pin cushion
it's very slow growing so it it has a
different biology and
it has not probably been selected the
way caffeine and
caffeine producing plants
and opium producing plants have
been selected and have evolved to
produce more of their of their chemical
uh it's it's it's still a wild plant so
it's in a different
realm
what's interesting about these plants
and these chemicals is that
they're not lethal in small doses
and if you think about it from a plant's
point of view which i'm always trying to
do
you don't want to necessarily kill your
pest
because if you do you're going to select
for resistant members of the pest
population this is how evolution works
and eventually that pesticide will no
longer work because you have evolve and
we see this with you know roundup and
all sorts of
human-made pesticides they don't work if
they're too lethal and use too much of
them
but if you merely mess with the minds of
your pests if you distract them from
what they're doing if you ruin their
appetite
that is a much better
strategy i used to have a cat who loved
catnip had a real problem with catnip
and every night would follow me into the
garden to have some catnip which i had
planted for him his name was frank
i noticed though every night he had to
be reminded where the plant was in the
garden because the catnip had cleverly
caused him to forget
um so it's these kind of you know really
ingenious uh mental tricks that plants
play on us that make them so effective
caffeine is a very interesting example
because
it is a pest to many insects and it
keeps other plants from growing too
close to the to the coffee or tea plant
but it was recently discovered by a
scientist working in england
named geraldine wright
that
certain plants produce caffeine this
poison supposedly in their nectar which
is where of course you want to attract
insects you want to attract honeybees
and and this scientist geraldine figured
out doing this experiment that actually
the bees were more attracted to caffeine
producing plants and the ones that had
access to caffeine had a better memory
for where those plants were were more
likely to return to it and they were
more effective pollinators so in effect
the caffeine is doing to the bees what
it's doing to us making us much better
workers
much more efficient workers that's
astounding and it's you know so we
should never underestimate the ingenuity
of plants they've been at this longer
than we have right i mean they've been
evolving these these complicated
neurochemistries for a very long time
and they've gotten really good at it
yeah it's it's mind-blowing isn't it
when you think about it um
just related to that last
topic in terms of the difference between
masculine and these other
other other plants is mescaline
addictive at all
no like most psychedelics they're not
habit-forming you know if you
do that classic setup with the rat in
the cage and they have two levers and
one administers a drug to their
bloodstream in one sugar water
and they'll you know if you put cocaine
or um or morphine in there they'll keep
doing it until they're addicted or
they're dead you do you put a
psychedelic in there and they've done
this with lsd they'll try it once and
then never again animals don't like to
trip
apparently and
one of the striking things about
psychedelics is that they are not
habit-forming
your first reaction after you've had a
psychedelic experience which is long and
tiring and and kind of mentally
exhausting is is not to do it again
anytime soon
they're also remarkably non-toxic the
classic psychedelics and that is um an
important fact not to say that there
aren't risks there are serious
psychological risks with psychedelics
and they're people who should stay away
from them
but they're much less toxic and much
less habit-forming than many drugs that
we use
so you have written widely about
regulation of these drugs and these
plants um and you clearly have your own
views about how that's been done in the
past
if you are going to be designing an
ideal society going forward what kind of
relationship should we be having with
plants and drugs
well i've been thinking about this a lot
i just wrote a piece about what happens
after the drug war you can find it on my
website or on the new york times website
it's called how should we do drugs now i
think is the title um and you know the
drug war in the us at least i i don't
think this is quite happening in the uk
yet but in the us is coming to an end i
mean
the voters are suing for peace they
their various ballot initiatives they've
passed that have decriminalized uh all
drugs in some places psychedelics and
other places so we are at that moment of
having to think about what does the
peace look like after the drug war and i
don't have the answers
i think it's a very important cultural
process to figure this out
i think that
people
who want to experiment with psychedelics
should not be doing it in a casual way
should be following some of these
principles we've been talking about of
how they're used successfully in
indigenous cultures
um i think we're developing this medical
container
but we also need to develop a container
for people who are not mentally ill
and still want and you want to use these
drugs for self-exploration or spiritual
development i think we're going to see
some psychedelic churches popping up in
america i think it's happening already
and that someday soon you may be able to
go to you know the church of lysergic
acid i mean i don't i don't know what
it'll be called but um and that given
our
uh supreme court and their deference to
anybody who
claims a religious uh right
uh to be exempt from federal laws
they're gonna they're gonna have trouble
saying no when these uh psychedelic
churches come to the come to the supreme
court
um in the case of the hard drugs uh we
know one thing the drug war hasn't
worked um we still have a problem with
addiction
um what is addiction i think we're
undergoing a kind of rethink about that
um
i mean as you know as a doctor you know
it's curious that most people who use
even hard drugs don't get addicted um so
what causes addiction well there's a lot
of evidence that it's it's
your circumstance um if you look at the
geography of the opiate crisis it's it's
it's concentrated in areas where
economic prospects are terrible where
people are out of work
where uh the future looks really bleak
and that using an opiate uh or
methamphetamine gives a kind of pleasure
that isn't available anywhere else
and it's just and it's a form of self
medication so we have to ask ourselves
is addiction the the disease or is it a
symptom of the disease and to what
extent is the disease social and
economic
um
and you know there's a very interesting
experiment underway in switzerland the
way they treat heroin addiction right
now is they will if you enter into this
government supported program
they will give you a prescription for
heroin because it's much safer to use it
if you know exactly what you're getting
and you have a clean needle and it's not
laced with fentanyl
and then after they've stabilized you
they they make sure you have a good job
they make sure you have good housing
they make sure you have therapeutic
support
and they understand that if you fix all
that first
then you can deal with the addiction
that the addiction comes after
um so i think that's an experiment well
worth watching um i think we have a lot
to learn and there's no glib answers i
mean addiction will be with us all right
we have problems with legal alcohol we
have certainly have problems with legal
nicotine um
it's going to be an uneasy piece
um but i think we can do a lot better
than locking up
millions literally millions of uh of
people in the united states for drug
non-violent drug crimes most of whom are
people of color
which brings me onto a question that
someone called rick has brought up and
actually relates to my concern which is
exactly what you just said which is that
so much in healthcare is actually to do
with the social context that we're in
um and you know capitalism
big business is already hovering
around these plants and the potential to
make big money from these these drugs
um
what do you see
being what we can put into place in
order to regulate how those companies
you know silicon valley entrepreneurs
pharmaceutical industry whoever
what can we do to make sure that their
desire to control patents and
intellectual property doesn't come in
the way
of
a these medications being available to
the people who need them but also b that
they're using exactly the right kinds of
context so that we don't have the
situation where we create another drugs
problem another opiate crisis yeah i
think that's a great question and
honestly i don't know all the answers i
i'm concerned about the attempt to
to control um these substances which
have been used for thousands of years uh
and i frankly i don't think it will be
successful
um
you know magic mushrooms are going to
grow no matter who owns the patent on
some crystalline form of it or a way of
manufacturing and that people can
conduct psychedelic therapy with actual
mushrooms and not just pills
however i do support the effort to
get these drugs through the the the
regulatory process
prove their value in in clinical trials
so that they will be much more
accessible because it's only through
that system so far that we know that you
can get it covered by insurance or by
national health and and and that's how
you're going to reach a lot of people
there the the affluent will be able to
seek their psychedelic therapy
underground if they want and use actual
mushrooms so i i think it's kind of a
fool's errand that you'll be able to
control these substances
they are you know
natural goods and um
uh and you really can't stop them from
being cultivated
but i do think that we have to
guard against the the commercialization
of things like psilocybin psilocybin is
very different than cannabis you know
there are 18 states in america now that
have
uh legalized
cannabis and you can go to a store and
buy it and and
here in the bay area where i live
they're billboards you know advertising
cannabis and that if you call now while
you're in your car they'll deliver it to
your home within two hours
and
cannabis is being put in candy and it is
being kind of pushed on people with the
result that cannabis uses is up in these
places um
i just think and a lot of people think
cannabis is the model for psilocybin and
that psilocybin should be sold next to
you know the thc gummy bear gummy bears
i think that's a big mistake i think
these are much more consequential
experiences i think they needed they
need to be regulated more carefully
and i don't think that
we want to leave psychedelics to the
mercies of capitalism you know outside
of the medical context
and you know just following on from that
over and above legalization which is
one conversation
one of our audience is concerned about
the fact that actually when you undergo
a psychedelic experience it can be
incredibly
profound transformative
very deep very mystical but not always
pleasant or not always easy to deal with
and
as well as thinking about all the
legalities of it and how we regulate it
is there a way that you can see us being
able to to do this safely to be able to
engage in in in the benefit of these
plants without necessarily bringing harm
to lots of people
well that's why i think the idea of the
guide or the facilitator who creates the
proper setting is so important
people do have very difficult
experiences on psychedelics even trips
you remember as being positive have very
scary moments very often where you're
feeling anxious or
threatened in some ways and
but the same experience when you're with
an experienced guide can be incredibly
productive
and these therapists don't talk about
bad trips they talk about challenging
trips and you know it may dredge up some
trauma from your past but you need help
processing that
and that's why
the so far in research there have been
very few adverse events
um because there's someone there to help
you to tell you what to do if things get
really frightening which essentially is
surrender to what's happening if you
feel your ego
dissolving or
or you feel like you're dying you you if
you resist what's happening to your ego
which is being
challenged by the drug
you'll get really anxious
and you could have a panic attack
whereas if you give yourself if you
surrender if you relax your mind and
float downstream as john lennon advised
many years ago
it will pass into a much happier place
so you need that guide on this journey
and without it is when you really risk
trouble
and
so that's why i don't think people
should use large doses of psychedelics
in a casual way or without proper
preparation or without someone who has
more experience than you but there are
also people who simply should not go
near these drugs and and one of the
values of having this
medical
container is that you qualify people you
know you take a medical history um does
this person have a relative who has
schizophrenia for example is there
evidence of mania or or some personality
disorder
in general those people are being
excluded
and are you on an ssri an antidepressant
not that that's dangerous but it won't
work very well because they occupy the
same receptors so
and then there are other psychedelics
like ibogaine which is very powerful in
the treatment of opiate addiction but
you really need to be on a heart monitor
when you're on that drug
so using that in a casual way is is
really dangerous
um so i think we have to treat these
substances with respect and and realize
that there is a way to use them that can
be very helpful to people with mental
illness and even without frankly people
who just feel
trapped in in destructive habits of
thought and behavior
stand to gain a lot from this
but getting the container right is is
vitally important
well i can tell from the questions that
we've been getting that you know people
who have been engaging in this
conversation or reading your book are
fascinated by this topic and they're
obviously curious to learn more um just
for the people who are watching tonight
there's a tab on the screen about the
psychedelic society um which for anyone
who's curious and i don't know if there
was anything you wanted to say about
that in particular michael no i i think
that for people who want to learn more
um well i would send you to my website
where i have a resources page with a
great amount of information about harm
reduction information and and actually a
listing of psychedelic societies in
cities all over the world um so you can
if you're not in london you can find one
michaelpollin.com just go to the
resources page uh plenty of free
information there for anybody who wants
to follow follow this up
uh and michael do you have any closing
thoughts before i let you go this
evening
uh no i but i want to thank you goody
for the conversation which has been um
incredibly uh stimulating to me and uh
you know i think we we are on the
edge of a potential revolution in mental
health care
mental health care has not been very
successful frankly i mean compare it to
any other branch of medicine it has not
prolonged life it has not cured disease
it's treated symptoms and not that well
the tools that we have are really
inadequate basically ssris and
antipsychotics that people hate taking
that have terrible side effects
um and we're very close to having
a better a set of better tools and
that's a very exciting moment it's going
to be treacherous in various ways um but
i think that we'll look back in five or
ten years and realize that um these
plants may bail us out uh in in ways
that we'll be very grateful for
uh and just before you leave because i'm
curious what are you working on next
i haven't yet uh launched on anything um
i've been very busy with this book and
there will be another book i can't stop
um but exactly what it will be i'm not
really sure yet as long as the book
title is good then i'm sure it'll be
fantastic
i'll do my best
michael thank you so much for
yeah i'm thanking you on behalf of the
audience but thank you so much for being
part of this conversation this evening
it's been absolutely fascinating from my
perspective and thank you for sharing
your new book this is your mind on plant
which is out now for anyone who would
like to buy um and yeah have a good
evening michael and i'm going to hand
back now to hannah from intelligence
squared goodnight everyone